[Musique]
Mexico Avec ses 20 millions d'habitants
reste la ville de tous les superlatifs
la plus grande la plus dangereuse la
plus
polluée et au milieu du FL ininterrompu
de la circulation for distingue et se
répète la forme familière d'une petite
voiture populaire née pourtant loin
d'ici il y a bien
longtemps des coccinelles à tous les
coins de rue et sur toutes les artères
des coccinelles de toutes les couleurs
de toutes les sortes des coccinelles
partout et pour tous comment sont-elles
arrivées jusqu'ici et si
[Musique]
nombreuses partie intégrante du paysage
urbain ces voitures d'une autre époque
continuent de proliférer et semblent
éternell mais pour combien de temps
encore déclaré nuisible et trop
nombreuse il semble qu'à Mexico la
chasse à la cocin est été
[Musique]
ouverte vol de mod
fait partie des milliers de taxis
quionnent en l'immensité de Mexico les
petites cxinelles blanch et vertes qui
au fil des décennies sont devenus un
symbole fort de la ville son blason en
quelque
[Musique]
sorte bonjour Comment ça va qu'est-ce
que vous avez j'ai tac à la milanaise ou
poulet ah donnez-moi une milanaise s'il
vous
plaît comment ça marche aujourd'hui ça
marche plutôt bien j'ai eu beaucoup de
courses ces dernières heures ça marche
bien
aujourd'hui et le trafic ça va par
contre le trafic c'est un peu dur en ce
moment et je me suis fait rentrer dedans
par une camionnette l'autre jour mais ça
va j'ai déjà
réparé
de
moi je fais partie des milliers de
chauffeurs de taxi qui sillonnent cette
ville et qui offrent le service public
pour mener à bien cette activité mon
vieil ami m'accompagne partout ce
véhicule c'est un excellent outil de
travail mais plus qu'un outil c'est un
très bon
ami tout le monde s'accorde à dire que
la coccinelle est une voiture
exceptionnelle et pour toutes ses
caractéristiques et à présent on
considère que le blanc et le vert sont
désormais classiques ils donnent les
couleurs de la vie à notre grande ville
et sont une partie intégrante de
l'identité de notre
vie mais malheureusement nos jours sont
à présent compé le ministère des
Transports prévoit la substitution de ce
vieux type de véhicule par des véhicules
neuf présentant des
caractéristiquesucos
nuevos de mejores
características
et devant les bureaux du ministère des
Transports la grogne des taxis coxinel
commence à se faire entendre il devient
de plus en plus compliqué de pouvoir
garder cet outil de travail quand on est
propriétaire d'une V il faut en
permanence renouveler son permis de
circuler et on passe des journées dans
les files d'attente au lieu de
travailler
remplacer petit à petit t les taxis de
la
ville plusoris que les
voituresort véhic RL plus les conditions
de sécurité minimum selon les autorités
il que les portes sont plus
S pour 2008 le ministère cherche en fait
à financer le remplacement de 5000
véhicules anciens par des voitures
modernesut faire disî
C ils nous ont dit qu'il all nous
recontacter pour nous indiquer la marche
à
suivre des cxin à profusion cette petite
voiture a visiblement tant proliféré au
cours des décennies qu'elle a fini par
se rendre indésirable mais comment la
cxinelle une voiture allemande d'avant
guerre est-elle arrivée
jusqu'ici
l'année 1954 marque l'entrée de la
Volkswagen au Mexique la voiture du
peuple est présentée à l'occasion de la
foire
mexico-allemande la même année elle se
fait encore remarquer du public sur la
ligne d'arrivée de la prestigieuse
course panaméricaine et le gouvernement
mexicain décide d'importer des modèles
en provenance de l'usine allemande de
volksburg et le succès commercial est
immédiat solide maniable accessible et
facilement réparable petite voiture
allemande à tout pour séduire la société
mexicaine des années
50 et en
1964 le gouvernement mexicain soucieux
de développer son industrie décide
simultanément d'interdire l'importation
de véhicules et de monter une usine
Volkswagen à
Puebla dès 1967 la 100000 sort de la
ligne d'assemblage la 5 D75 pour
atteindre le millionième véhicule en
la voiture est omniprésente sur le
marché mexicain d'autant qu'elle a été
choisie comme taxi officiel de la
capitale Mexico rev les couleurs de la
éigé en emblème de la
[Musique]
ville l'usine de exporte massivement
vers le monde entier compris vers
l'Europe et ironie de l'histoire c'est à
présent quin
[Musique]
l'allemagneéopé à lui seul 75 % de la
production mondiale dès 1990 le Mexique
devient le seul et dernier pays au monde
à fabriquer la voiture la plus populaire
de tous les
[Musique]
temps mais rien n'est éternel on appelle
cet endroit le cimetière des vautchoss
derrière ces grilles ce sont plus de
2500 coccinelles déclaré illégales qui
qui sont retenus prisonnières le coût de
l'infraction étant de plus d'un an de
salaire minimum peu sont les
propriétaires qui pourront récupérer
leur véhicule d'autant que le séjour en
ces lieux est court après 3 mois les
pensionnaires seront envoyés à la
destruction une stratégie pour accélérer
la disparition de la vacho dont ne se
cache pas l'inspecteur du ministère des
[Musique]
Transports la plupart des véhicules qui
sont ici sont des Volkswagen qui ont de
toute façon dépass leur temps de vie
utile et les autorités les retienent ici
pour essayer de renouveler le parc
automobile de la ville car les ne sont
plus autorisés pour offrir le service
public le renouvellement du parc
automobile implique de mettre en
circulation des véhicules 4 portes et
surtout des véhicules équipés de
technologie de contrôle antiution ce
sont des voitures qui sont trop vieilles
et la nouvelle limite d'âge pour la mise
en circulation d'un taxi à Mexico n'est
que de 3
ans
mais alors qu'on programme la
disparition de la petite voiture du
peuple dans les quartiers populaires de
la ville elle continue imperturbablement
à faire partie du décor et du
quotidien et quand on a 20 ans dans le
quartier de saintel et que l'on n pas
les moyens de s'offrir une voiture on
fait comme Ivan on se fabrique sa propre
coccinelle de récupération pièce après
pièce à force de combine de patience on
dit qu'à Mexico les coccinelles ont
plusieurs
[Musique]
vies comment ça se passe le travail au
garage ça marche
bien et ta voiture ça avance oui mais il
y a encore du boulot plein de pièces à
trouver mais je vais aller fouiller au
marché
dimanche courage pour continuer surtout
pour finir
vite il va falloir je suis le seul dans
le quartier à toujours pas avoir de
voiture et pour y remédieran rend
quotidiennement visite à ce qui sera un
jour sa voiture pour l'instant la
carcasse d'une cooccinelle 1300 de
1978 j'ai décidé d'acheter cette voiture
pour la remonter pièce par
pièces et ça me donne la satisfaction de
faire les choses par MO
me ça fait un an que je travaille sur ma
voch je pense qu'il va me falloir encore
une bonne
année mais à la fin elle sera unique et
elle me ressemblera elle aura ma
personnalité moi j'achète les pièces au
marché noir étant donné la situation
économique au Mexique c'est la seule
solution pour la plupart des gens il
faut fouiller partout pour trouver de
quoi fabriquer sa voiture les magasins
et les garages c'est beaucoup trop cher
[Musique]
est une figure dans le monde deseros
c'est un collectionneur réputé à Mexico
et audelà dans le monde de la Coxinelle
chef d'entreprise il est aussi président
du plus prestigieux club de
collectionneurs du pays et au volant de
son modè allemand de
1964 est
[Musique]
c'est conduire un morceau
d'histoire c'est aussi une manière
nostalgique de revenir dans le passé de
revenir un monde fait de choses simples
loin des
complications COS simples de de seé du
tout
technque
te c'est un trésor à mes yeux elle me
procure joie et bonne humeur on en a
vraiment besoin quand on doit conduire
dans une ville aussi compliquée que les
celle de
mexicoan complicada lai
deéic
direction les beaux quartiers de la
capitale pour rendre visite à son ami
Rous qui vient de faire une nouvelle
acquisition et l'entré dans la famille
d'un nouveau membre est toujours un
événement salut comment ça
va alors c'est ta nouvelle
voiture voil je te laés
19 elle est entièrement à
l'original tu la vois t qu'elle est
sortie de l'usine là tout est
d'époque fonction
clant commeu
sont incrobles ces voitures ça marche
toujours
impressionnant ça fonctionne comme une
machinerie
d'horloge rendre un modèle de 1956
l'éclat de sa jeunesse c'est un travail
long et hreux chaque détail compte mais
pour et amis rien sera trop cher pour
redonner à sa machine l'appar des belles
[Musique]
années
ation la restauration encore une fois
c'est Alexandro
Velasquez je le considère comme un
véritable
artiste pour moi c'est un des deux ou
trois meilleurs restaurateurs du
pays TR me
restaurador l'artiste c'est lui
Ardo
Vargas il a transformé son hangar en une
véritable caverne d'Alibaba où il fait
diton des miracles
Eduardo met son art au service d'une
clientèle fortunée qui attend de lui
qu'il transforme des vieilles carcasses
en pièces de
musée et en collectionneur averti vient
régulièrement rendre visite à Eduardo et
ses pensionnaires au cas où il y aurait
une belle acquisition à
faire ça me fait plaisir de te voiroi
ne tu vois toujours ou en train de
retaper mes
voitures et
toi je passé par là et puis je voulais
venir jeter un coup d'œil à tes
pensionnaires voir si tu avais de
nouvelles choses spécialement celle-là
m'intéresse beaucoup
Eduardo fait partie de ceux qui ont
compris que demain à Mexico la
coccinelle deviendra l'affaire des plus
riches le marché de la cooccinelle est
en train d'évoluer ici il cesse d'être
populaire ça devient un marché plus
sélectif et qui est de plus en plus
réservé à une clientèle
fortunée en tout cas ici ont mis
avantout sur la restauration haut de
gamme je suis sur ce créneau parce que
je pense que c'est ça l'avenir de la
VOO je crois que d'ici une dizaine
d'années on verra presque plus de VOO
circuler dans les rues de cette ville et
malheureusement ce sera une partie du
patrimoine populaire de notre
d'un garage à l'autre et d'une réalité à
l'autrevan travaille dans l'atelier de
son oncle lis un atelier à même la rue
comme ça se fait ici à force de
bricolage et de raistolage on se
consacre à faire survivre jour après
jour les
[Musique]
v alors ça
avance plus ou Mo du cas pour pouvoir
bien
continuer quand est-ce que tu penses
Tavoir terminé il me faut encore un
an tu arrives pas à trouver les pièces
ou quoi pour ça il me faudrait plus de
temps et surtout plus
d'argent il faut que tu ailles au marché
de
couran tu plaisantes il y a des flics
partout là-bas et qui contrôle sans
arrêt de quoi as-tu besoin en
fait les intérieurs les accessoires et
surtout les pièces du
moteur il te faut presque tout oui
heureusement j'ai déjà la
carrosserie ben bon
courage si trouve encore partout au
Mexique c'est parce que c'est la voiture
la plus facile à répar il y a des pièces
partout même à la pharmacie tu peux en
trouver vraiment tu la répares partout
cette
voiture mespr bon mécano il cherche ses
pièces partout ça fait des mois qu'il
travaille dur et je suis certain qu'il
aura terminé dans peu de temps sa petite
[Musique]
Vito posé un peu partout comme des
aquarelles qui seraient là pour flatter
le regard parfaitement installé dans un
décor des lumières et des couleurs conçu
tout spécialement pour elle on les voit
plus pour ce qu'elles sontte de caméléon
MC fond dans le environnement dans les
rues de paraissent au soleil avec
élégance
[Musique]
et visite à son voisin Man qui lui a de
rusciter dans son arrièrecours l'on
imaginerait
irrécupérable tu as vu je suis en train
de retaper
celle-là si tu arrives à remettre ça en
marche alors moi je pourrais y arriver
avec la
mienne et bien c'est un modèle de 1966
et je vais la restaurer à
l'original à l'original façon de parler
oui c'est vrai elle est un peu vieille
elle est un peu abîmée mais elle sera
très bien l'arrivée tu verras tu arrives
à trouver des pièces toi oui mais c'est
vrai qu'il n'y en a plus tant que ça
c'est un très vieux modèle en plus et la
porte ferm bien
oui oui je te dis qu'elle
marche ça c'est une pièce originale de
Porsche
ouais c'est un Angol Porsche d'origine
mais il tient pas encore parce que je
cherche aussi les vis d'origine je veux
que des pièces
allemandes
et toi comment ça AV avec
laen encore queles mois je pense j'ai
encore tout à
trouverir dans des bouques spécialisé
cherche sur internetet c'est trop cher
moi je cherche vraiment les plus petits
[Musique]
prix com
bience reste à faire dans 2 semaines
j'attaque la peinture il me reste peu de
chose il faut encore passer
les pass
peinture V
intérieurs la tapisserie
aussi dans 15
jours oui dans 15 jours tout plus c'est
bon est bien Liss en plus tu vois
après il me restera la rapprocher un
petit peu du sol et à régler les
derniers détailes dierentes R s
[Musique]
tamb nous sommes loin du quartier
d'ivane dans le garage de la maison
familiale Carlos garde intact bien à
l'abri du monde et du temps qui passe la
berline 1200 année 1956 de son défunt
père plus qu'un garage Carlos en a fait
un sanctuaire qui renferme la mémoire
d'une autre
[Musique]
époque cette voiture fait partie du
patrimoine de la famille pas seulement
le patrimoine économique c'est surtout
un patrimoine affectif nous venons
souvent lui rendre visite en souvenir de
mon
père cette voiture elle fait partie de
notre famille depuis
1969 depuis toutes ces années elle est
là
PARM et Carl c'est Daniela nos enfants
l'adorent
aussi mon mari passe des heures et des
heures à la frotter à la faire briller
je sais d'ailleurs pas s'il caresse plus
sa voiture que sa
femme mais c'est bien comme ça ça vaut
la peine ça vaut vraiment la peine
la tu es venu rendre visite à la voiture
de ton père je suis venu jeter un petit
coup d'œil comment tu te portes très
bien et
toi tu fouilles dans la voiture de ton
père tu trouves des
souvenirs oui tu vois j trouve beaucoup
de souvenirs regarde par exemple ce que
je
trouve un plan de la villeant de 19
[Musique]
et tu veux encore y trouver beaucoup de
belles
choses cette voiture renferme beaucoup
de beaux et vieux souvenirs mes enfants
ont grandi auprès d'elles ils ont bien
profité de leur
voito elle me rappelle de très beaux
souvenirs des souvenirs très éloignés
quand la ville de Mexico était autre
chose et qu'on pvait s promener
CIN on prenait la voiture avec les
enfants pour aller se promener
tranquillement et mon mari qui était
tellement fier de sa voiture plus que de
sa famille
[Musique]
peut-être où est donc passée la douceur
de vivre à Mexico mégalopole
tentaculaire elle est devenue durant la
deuxè moitié du 20e siècle une ville
[Musique]
irrespirable les 20 millions d'habitants
de Mexico vivent dans des émanations de
gaz d'échappement dépassant tous les
records et la circulation automobile
devient ici un enjeu majeur de santé
publique pour libérer la capitale de sa
chape toxique la vieille amie k la
cxinelle est du
[Musique]
Do y est responsable du laboratoire
d'études atmosphérique de l'Université
de Mexico et pour lui il y a urgence à
libérer les rues de la ville de cette
petite voiture qui est surtout un grand
pollueur pour les scientifiques comme
moi qui travaillent à Mexico c'est un
vrai challenge de réussir a déterminé
quel impact la VOO a sur la qualité de
l'air on a un vrai problème avec la
présence
d'oxyde
d'hydrocarbone de particules toxiques
dans l'air et cela est principalement d
à la circulation automobile et c'est à
cause de ça que l'air de Mexico est si
mauvais sucessif n'auront pas réussi à
maîtriser le problème de la pollution
atmosphérique à Mexico le développement
urbain sauvage la concentration
exponentielle de la population
l'implantation des aéroports au cœur de
la ville ont contribué à
l'empoisonnement de l'air mais la ville
pâti également de sa situation
géographique posé à 2500 m d'altitude la
faible pression ralentit la dissolution
des gaz de plus Mexico est encerclé par
une chaîne de haute montagne qui empêche
les vents de circuler et entre la
pollution aujourd'hui le gouvernement
semble prendre conscience de l'urgence
et des solutions sont à
l'étude les scientifiques travaillent en
association avec le gouvernement local
pour essayer d'améliorer la qualité de
l'air de Mexico on peut citer en exemple
une législation en vigueur depuis
quelques années et qui vise à limiter
les émissions toxiques des voitures en
obligeant les conducteurs à faire
contrôler deux fois par an leur
véhiculle
évidemment une voiture comme la VO n'est
pas équipée de système de contrôle
antiollution et dès lors ces voitures
comme d'autres ont tendance à être
supprimé de la circulation et cela dans
le but d'améliorer la qualité de l'air à
Mexico
la coccinelle décriée la coccinelle
menacée mais ce contexte polémique et
hostile n'empêche pas la famille
mexicaine de voouir un amour sans borne
pour
Saito et au-delà des clivages sociaux on
aime se retrouver aux alentours de
Mexico par de belles journées ensoleillé
pour célébrer tous ensemble et en
famille cette machine dont on dit qu'il
n'est pas un mexicain qui au cours de sa
vie nen est possédé au moins
une
[Musique]
Alberto fait partie du jury c'est à lui
que revient le privilège d'évaluer les
belles candidates pour les prix selon
catégorie un mélange savant de critères
objectifs et
[Musique]
deentada
parreore
partici éénès famux on aime venir avec
tout le monde emmener tous les
ENF ici au Mexique comme ailleurs dans
le monde nous sommes très nombreux à
partager cette passion pour
lesci c'est toujours une grande fé pour
nous propriéire
d'untis
Volkswagen fatigable mais à la fois une
voiture très sélee et on peut la
modifier à l'infini pour moi c'est
simplement la meilleure voiture du
monde l'essentiel dans notre jugement
c'est que la voiture est gardait sa
forme authentique le principal est que
sa forme originale é bien préservé on
peut changer plein de choses le moteur
les amortisseurs mais mieux sa ligne
originale sera conservée mieux elle sera
jugée
bonito
[Musique]
et ici on trouvera de tout et pour tous
les goûts essentiellement des modèles
sortis de l'usine de Puebla entre 1964
et 2003 berline de luxe des années 50 et
60 Super cxinel Silver bug et spéal bugs
qui ont inondé les marchés des années 70
et 80 l'indémodable et déjà classique
modèle 1600 et la désormais légendaire
ultime édition de 2003 sans oublier un
bon nombre d'hybrides joyeux patchwork
de modèle de type et
d'anné que T por dentro estés
[Musique]
llorando a
meereserg
car j'ai cette voiture il 4 ans depuis
toujours mattend dans le garage de la
maison maintenant je l'ai
bienetap je
trette je la changer pour rien au
[Musique]
monde si on se marie plusard avec mon
bébé je garderai celle-ci pour les
concours je lui offrirai à elle une
familiale et j'en prendrai une sportive
pour
moi en compte que l'on fait ses projets
de couple et d'avenir mais puisquelle
est unfant de plus dans la famille
Ty l'amour qu'elle sucite chez son
propriétaire peut justement poser des
problèmes de couple et les épouses la
voi plus souvent comme une maîtresse
rivale cette voiture est un cadeau d'un
oncle de Mexico quand je l'ai récupéré
elle était en très mauvais état et j'ai
réussi à en faire un vrai petit
bijou c'est de l'amour que l'on ressent
pour une vot ch il faut la
respecter c'est vraiment de l'amour que
l'on ressent pour elle
c'est vrai que l'amour que l'te à la est
si grand que parfois on oublie la
famillee tellement de temps qu'on en
néglige le reste j'aime plus ma voiture
que ma femme et tu vois elle est fâché
tellement j'aime ma
[Musique]
VO je ne suis pas
jalouse j'avou qu'il passe plus de temps
avec sa voiture qu'c ses
enfants mais on l'accompagne toujours
dans
less
par et voici la Volkswagen t qu'on
l'aime c'est dans cet état qu'onapécie
le plus en fait au Mexique on aime qu'
porte sur elle la trace des anné qu'elle
nous montre le temps qui a passé et
Monelle est toujours là avec nous
je veux rien toucher sur cette voiture
tu veux dire que tu veux la conserver
dans cet état la laisser à l'original
sans essayer d'effacer les traces des
années sur
elle oui je l'ai acheté il y a 2 ans
j'ai presque rien changé juste un peu
ramené vers le sol et surtout je n'ai
pas retouché à la
peinture et je crois que tu as raison
important de la conserver enétat ça vaut
la peine ça vaut la peine d'essayer
d'alléguer aux prochaines générations
dans cet état à
l'original l'utopie d'une voiture du
peuple semble bien s'être finalement
réalisé ici au Mexique une utopie
pourant venue de loin et des PES les
plus sombres de l'histoire due
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
siècle toutes les grandes marques ont
leur histoire et leur légendes
respectives mais on sait que dans le cas
de Volkswagen la particularité et
qu'elle est née en Allemagne avant la
guerre sous le régime
nazi un des rêves du national socialisme
était d'offrir au peuple allement une
voiture populaire de proposer un moyen
de transport pour chaque citoyen
allemand Hitler tenait beaucoup à ce
projet et il a demandé à ferdin Porsche
un designer por aile é enc àette épo de
lu faire des
propositionserd
porscheésat de ces travaux auens
allemand et parmi les différentes
propositions Hitler re le modèle de
Volkswagen que nous
con
Volks pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
l'usine de volbg s'est mise à fabriquer
principalement des véhicules de
combat comme la
kubenwagen ou la fameuse schwiwagen de
fa div
éent Laer fin
Laer de la allemande l'usine est tombée
sous administration des forces alliées
et en particulier des Britanniques
ils ont découvert une usine
partiellement détruite et dans les
décombres ils ont retrouvé quelques
exemplaires de
Volkswagen afin de redonner du travail
aux Allemands mais surtout pour
récupérer le projet Volkswagen les
Alliés ont remis l'usine en
marche et à partir des morceaux retrouv
ça là se exemplaires ont été
reconstitués les se voitures ont été
présé à l'é
é la production a été remise en marche
et c'est ainsi qu'à la fin de l'année
1945 le milliè exemplaire de Volkswagen
sortait de l'usine de que a servir las
tropas
[Musique]
aliadas la Volkswagen moderne était donc
né près de décennies sont passé depuis
et visiblement sous ces latitudes les
années et les révolution technologique
successive n'ont jamais eu prise sur
elle et c'est la crème de la crème qui
défile ce matin dans le centre de la
ville des modèles allemands et mexicains
des années 50 et 60
[Musique]
immaculé les membres du Carman VV
vintage club aim retrouver au cœur de la
ville par dimanche matin entre gens de
la bonne société et partag un breakfast
dans un restaurant chic aujourd'hui a
réuni ses amis collectionneurs dans les
jardins du palais
[Musique]
présidentiel moi j'ai acheté cette
voiture par nostalgie pour prolonger la
tradition familiale mon père avait une
Volkswagen et quand j'ai appris qu'il
arrê définitivement de la fabriquer j'ai
décidé de vite m' procurer
une je voulais avoir cette voiture
représentative de toute ma
génération et une voiture qui m' rappelé
tant de beau souvenirs une voiture qui
pourrait prolonger
l'héritage j'aime vraiment cette voiture
c'est ma favorite c'est ma
passion j'adore
Volkswagen c'est lere de voitureonore
on en a trois à la maison c'est très
important pour notre famille de les
avoir d'en prendre soin de leur procurer
des nouvelles pièces pour notre
collection c'est toujours une grande
satisfaction d'être propriétaire d'une
Volkswagen quand on est au volant de
cette voiture à travers les rues de
Mexico les se retour sur
sonage il la trouve très belle élégante
incroyable
étonnante mais la maintenir dans cet
état n'est pas
facile
compou
siitable c'est vrai ça devient V
compliqué de
l'entretenir mais on ne fait pas ça pour
la
rentabilité voyz une fascination pour
elle qui est toujours liée chez le
collectionneur au souvenir de l'enfance
c'est un symptôme
commun quand j'étais petit mon père
avait une coccinelle et je me souviens
que j'étais complètement fasciné par sa
forme je l'adorais et parfois j'allais
me cacher pour dormir dans le coffre de
la
voiture je rêvais d'en avoir une quand
je seraiis adulte et je me disais que le
jour où je l'aurai je ferai tout pour la
garder dans son état
d'origine et je pense que dans l'avenir
elle est promis une disparition certaine
parce que les technologies ont trop
évolué
aujourd'hui elle sera bientôt réserver
un cercle très fermé de collectionneurs
passionnés qui feront tout pour les
maintenir en
étatut
[Musique]
[Rires]
dimanche c'est aussi le jour du marché
et àan dans le sud de la ville on trouve
de tout et au meilleur prix
[Musique]
entre la nourriture l'électroménager et
les vêtements on trouvera aussi de quoi
habiller sa
cxinelle
[Musique]
Ivan connaî les adresses et les combine
pour récupérer une à une les pièces de
son
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
puzzle bueno aquí podemos encontrar je
suis à la recherche de pièces pour le
moteur dans ce marché tu peux trouver
plein de pièces de
cinelle c'est là que c'est le moins
cher je pense trouver mais par contre il
faut pas trop se demander d'O viennent
les
pièces
aujourd'hui je cherche des pièces de
Volkswagen est-ce que tu en
Auris pour les là j'ai des
multiplicateur
distributeur des carburateurs je vois
j'en ai mais sont pas pour
des les direction oui c'eston
volksagen trouver des pièces de modèles
récents que tu peux monter sur des
modèles
anciens tu peux faire fonctionner ta
voiture avec toutes les pièces que tu
trouver ici ancienne neuve ou maises
semiuv mais tout est moins cher car ma
clientèle c'est les gens qui sont
fauchés ici tu peux trouver toutes les
pièces de votre show de tous les modèles
et de toutes les années vieilles récent
modifié aprè mé tout pour faire ta
voiture et tu cré ce qu'on appelle un
frankensteinenes consuir piezas de fait
ce que tu trouves ici la plupart du
temps ce sont des pièces qui ont été
volées sur les voitures dans tout
Mexico et tu peux tomber sur tes propres
pièces que tu t'es fait
voler mais même si je retrouve une pièce
dont je suis sûr qu'elle est à moi je ne
pourrais rien dire je pourrais pas
protester et je n'aurais plus qu'à la
racheter de
nouveau c'est comme ça c'est les
affaires des machines de récupération
faites de brique et de broc comme des
anticailles que l'on rafistole à
l'infini il n'y a pas si longtemps
pourtant elle sortaiit encore flamban
neuve des lignes d'assemblage de Puebla
et demeurit la fierté de la nation mais
à Puebla la Volkswagen Sedane déj un
lointain souvenir depuis 2003 la new
BEATLE est venu la remplacer et a ouvert
une nouvelle ère conso morales
directrice des ventes nous explique les
raisons de ce passage d'un monde à
l'autre nous avons arrêté de produire la
cxinelle en
2003 dans cette usine nous en avons
produit plus de
1600000 aujourd'hui on trouve sur le
marché mexicain une grande diversité de
véhicules des caristiques très
modernes clairement la technologie de la
cxinel a pu fonctionner parfaitement
pendant un grand nombre d'années mais en
2003 elle était devenue complètement
obsolète elle ne répondait plus au
caract minimum ex par lesres
paysay plus
d'ailles une technie plus avancée malgré
la forme qui est un peu similaire la
nubitel est une voiture complètement
différente elle est conçue avec des
technologie de pointe et nous sommes la
seule usine au monde à fabriquer la
newle nous l'expons aujourd'hui vers
plus de
pay la única planta que produce el new
para too el mundo lo exportamos as de 80
pases malgré ce succès affiché sur les
lignes d'assemblage de la New Beetle on
semble loin d'avoir oublié les anné
et on repense avec nostalgie à une autre
manière de fabriquer des
voituresis
[Musique]
souviennent la différence entre les deux
est énorme je me souviens de l'événement
organisé pour la sortie du dernier
modèle il rég une atmosphère de
nostalgie et
d'émotion ma première voiture était une
voito et je crois que pour nous les
mexicain elle restera tout à fait
unique la manière de travailler était
vraiment familiale aujourd'hui avec la
new bele tout est
automatisé on se souvient des moments
heureux qu'on avait en travaillant sur
Lao j'ai chance de travailler sur les
deux mod mod ancien coxinel et cette
innovation qui est à présent la
newit la coxinel on l'a fabriqué à la
main de manière très
artisanale aujourd'hui on travaille avec
de nouvelles
technologies une nouvelle manière de
travailler quand s'est achevé la
production de la seddane le 30 juillet
2003 nous avons vraiment basculer dans
une a nouvelle celle de la technologie
et
deinnovation sur le site de Puebla il
est un hangar qui n'est pas comme les
autres dans ce qui est aujourd'hui
devenu un site de stockage plusieurs
générations d'ouvriers ont assemblé
entre 1964 et 2003 près de 2 millions de
coccinel
il flotte ici une atmosphère tout à fait
particulière et tout employé de
Volkswagen Mexico voit ici un lieu de
[Musique]
mémoire trouvons dans le regard 21 de
l'usine Volkswagen
Mexico c'est aujourd'hui un centre de
stockage de pièces destiné à la
production des nouveaux
véhicules mais il flotte ici une
atmosphère de nostalgie puisque pendant
tant d'années c'est ici que l'on assembl
la
ici avaite l'étape finale de
l'assemblage et elle sortait d'ici prê
être distribué dans tout le
pays l'endroit est rempli de
nostalgie on y repense à toutes ces
années et on ressent une partie
importante de l'histoire de
Volkswagen à la fin de la production de
[Musique]
la
dans les sous-sols de la fourrière de
Mexico repos déjà ces vestiges d'une
autre époque t des prisonnières arborant
leur numéro de détenu elles attendent
leur fin c'est en quelque sor ici qui
est en train de mourir cette utopie
d'une voiture du peuple d'une voiture
par et pour le peuple une utopie qui
aura traversé les remous de l'histoire
pendant près de 80 années et dont on a
pu croire qu'elle survivrait toujours
[Musique]
un rêve mais aussi un patrimoine
industriel et historique inestimable
dont la destruction est rigoureusement
programmée mais tant que les v chos
continuent de sillonner les rues de
Mexico et d'habiter les arrièrecours des
immeubles et tant que des hommes
gagneront avec ell leur pain quotidien
nul doute que la résistance aura lieu et
que chacun sera bien décidé à vivre avec
elle
[Musique]
pourquoi attendre un Mo si tu as de la
chance et pourquoi devoir venir tous les
jours pour demander où on est le
dossier de toute façon il manque
toujours une signature parci et une
signature par là on dirait que la terre
entière doit signer le
papieri malheureusement nous somes
me
il faut bien comprendre que le véhicule
qui se retrouve là-dedans c'est la
source de travail pour au moins deux
chauffeurs et un propriétaire
c'est-à-dire que tu te retrouves avec
trois familles qui n'ont plus de
revenus et là on pourrait demander
l'application de la Constitution sur le
droit du
travail mais Manolo et ses compagnons
d'infortune ont le sentiment de se
battre contre des intérêts qui les
dépassent et Sansen prendre au coccinel
c'est aussi remettre en cause le seul
service public de transport de la ville
ils ont mis ma coccinelle là-dedans pour
des raisons qu'il n'arrivent même pas à
justifier ce qui me gêne le plus c'est
qu'il nous mène en bateau ils ne
prennent pas le temps de nous écouter on
a fait toutes les démarche on a payé
toutes les
amendes on a fait tout ce qu'il nous
demandait mais eux il nous traitent
comme si on éta des
délinquants il nous laisse attendre en
plein soleil et personne vient nous
VO moi j'offre le service public de
transport dans cette ville j'essaie de
faire le mieux possible et au meilleur
tarif mais il préfèrent nous cataloguer
comme délinquant et nous laisser là sous
le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soleil et bien loin des polémiques bien
loin des complots contre la voito Ivan
et ses copains continuent de vivre au
quotidien auprès d'elle et non Dieu que
pour elle et une fois qu'Ivan aura donné
vie à sa vieille carcasse de cxinelle il
voudra sans doute en refaire vivre une
autre encore il transmettra sans doute
cette manie à ses enfants c'est comme ça
elle a ce on ne sait quoi en plus qui
lui confère une aura et qui en fait un
membre de la famille salut
salut tu es encore là ah ouais ça B ici
ça B dur comment elle va ta cox ça va
aucun problème tu me montres la tienne
ouais viens je vais te
montrer depuis qu'on la fabrique plus la
seule alternative c'est bien d'apprendre
à les faire et aller refaire nous-mêmes
nous autres les mexicains et avec nos
propres
moyens pour cela le plus important c'est
d'avoir un cœur de V et d'appartenir à
cette
tradition mure que les pièces deviennent
rares la tradition va doucement se
perdre c'est de plus en plus difficile
de trouver des pièces de coccinel et
c'est pour ça qu'elle risque de bientôt
disparaître des
rues mais c'est comme une petite
bataille qui a commencé et si on perd on
devra se trouver d'autres loisirs moi je
crois pas que ça arrive j'espère plutôt
que cette situation va nous faire à tous
prendre conscience que c'est important
de la préserver d'en prendre soin et
surtout qu'ici on est vraiment amoureux
d'elle tantito
cariño señor presidente le VO a
avisar no se va a pagar señor presidente
le vengo a avisar que la de no se va a
apagar me gusta la leche me gusta el
café pero más me
gustausted me gusta la leche me gusta el
café pero más me gustan los ojos de
[Musique]
usted